if we find aliens what do we do next
when discussing first contact many are
quick to point out that historically
contact between culturally different
civilizations has almost always led to
the destruction of one of those
civilizations because of this you could
argue that we should stick to ourselves
leave the aliens alone but in almost
every one of those historical examples
its the civilization that makes contact
that destroys the civilization that
receives contact so perhaps we should go
on the offensive find the aliens before
they find us of course we've been trying
for decades to find extraterrestrial
life it's one of humanity's great
questions are we alone one way we might
find aliens is by looking at stars or
more specifically the light level of
stars as the earth has developed our
energy consumption has skyrocketed
that's just the consequence of an
increasingly technologically advanced
world it's suspected that this trend
will continue
and it's also suspected that with any
alien civilization they'll also require
more and more energy as they advance
eventually any planetary civilization
will reach a point where the amount of
energy on their planet is not enough to
sustain their advancing civilization
theoretical physicist Freeman Dyson
speculated that when a planetary
civilization needs more energy than
their planet can provide they'll turn to
the Sun stars are the most abundant
source of energy in any planetary system
so a super advanced civilization could
build a series of satellites to orbit
around their Sun to collect energy when
sunlight travels through space it loses
energy until the amount of energy
captured by a solar panel near the Sun
would be astronomically higher than a
solar panel on earth with more energy as
civilization could produce more
satellites and eventually there would be
a swarm of satellites orbiting the Sun
Freeman Dyson believes that this is the
most logical way that any civilization
would harvest the energy they need so if
we search for a star with orbiting
satellites we might be able to find an
alien civilization no telescope is
powerful enough to see the individual
satellites but we can rather easily
observe the light level of stars you see
once a faraway civilization building
satellites the swarm will start to block
our view of their son as the satellites
orbit from our perspective it will look
like this star is twinkling something
completely unnatural so by looking for
stars with highly variable light levels
we might be able to find an alien
civilization harvesting the energy of
their Sun kic eight four six two eight
five two also known as tabby star is a
star in the Cygnus constellation of the
Milky Way scientists observe the light
level of this star for years and they
regularly came across irregularities
like this maybe there are comments or a
debris field obstructing our view of
this star but astronomers have doubted
that either of those could dip the light
levels by this much this has led some to
suggest that an alien civilization has
built these orbiting satellites around
their Sun but we may never know for
certain of course all of this is
somewhat speculative and it's unlikely
that we'd actually find a so-called
Dyson Sphere around a Sun it's more of a
thought experiment demonstrating that we
could find aliens through looking for
their impact on the universe conversely
aliens might find us based on our effect
on the universe that's why we very
purposely sent out messages to our
hypothetical cosmic neighbors the
pioneer plaques were designed and placed
on the to pioneer spacecrafts which were
the first to explore the far reaches of
the solar system since these two are
some of the farthest man-made objects
from Earth they were sent with a message
in case extraterrestrials come across
the probes this is what was sent the
pioneer plaque it has a representation
of hydrogen the most abundant element in
the universe a picture of a man and
woman including a raised hand a gesture
that most likely wouldn't be understood
but shows how our limbs move and the
existence of the opposable thumb an
image of the Pioneer spacecraft behind
the humans so that the extraterrestrials
could figure out the rough size of
humans the location of the Sun relative
to 14 nearby pulsar stars using hydrogen
spin flip transition frequency as the
unit something far too complicated for
me to explain and lastly an image of the
solar system with the rough trajectory
of the Pioneer spacecraft but there are
issues with this image we have no idea
how
aliens gather information humans are a
visual species since we have relatively
good vision so it's natural for us to
convey information through images aliens
on the other hand could have poor or no
vision and therefore no conception of
the idea of transferring information
through images or they could interpret
the symbols vastly differently
perhaps the most frequently criticized
aspect of the plaque is the arrow it's
believed that the arrow symbol is
derived from either the shape of arrows
or the human hand pointing or perhaps a
combination of both
aliens would most likely have neither
arrows or hands and therefore no idea
what this symbol means they could also
make the dangerous assumption that the
symbol depicts a weapon launching
meaning that the spacecraft was sent to
harm them other sets of images have been
sent with subsequent space probes but
the chance of aliens finding these few
tiny objects in the vastness of space is
miniscule what's far more likely is that
aliens will discover humanity off of
something we've been sending out for
over a hundred years radio signals while
most are too weak to reach faraway
galaxies some do travel through space
and could be picked up by
extraterrestrial civilizations
especially more advanced ones with
better detection technology than us it's
entirely possible that we've already
unintentionally sent the signal that
will be our first message to an
extraterrestrial civilization it's also
entirely possible that the first sign we
will have of extraterrestrial life is a
radio message from another planet the
problem is then deciphering it the first
step is deciding what the message even
is is a binary is a radiation is a
natural language what is it we can
figure this out in the English language
the most common word the accounts for
about seven percent of all word
occurrences the second most common word
e accounts for about 3.5 percent of all
words then and is about 2.3 percent and
so on and so forth the distribution of
words it turns out in all languages
follows a logarithmic scale the second
most common word occurs about half as
frequently as the most common the third
1/3 is often the fourth one fourth is
often the fifth one fifth is often and
so on and so forth this is somehow true
for all languages E
with no common ancestral language which
means that more than likely an alien
language will follow the same
distribution it's not entirely
understood why languages follow this
distribution but one possible
explanation is that people are lazy it's
called a principle of least effort
people animals even machines will always
pick the path of least resistance the
easiest path and in the case of language
the meaning that needs to be most
frequently conveyed will be attached to
the most common word rather than a
number of other words since that is
easiest that keeps happening down to the
least frequent word therefore creating
this distribution with an
extraterrestrial transmission if we rank
the sounds by frequency and it follows
this distribution we can believe that
it's most likely a language but then we
need to try to understand the language
for this we need to drop all assumptions
there are innate similarities across all
human languages mostly related to
grammar for example pretty much every
language separates description words
nouns from action words verbs
grammatically there are huge
similarities between all languages even
ones that develop separately some have
suggested that this means that humans
have a genetic framework for language
perhaps we are hardwired from birth to
understand what nouns and verbs and
sentences are and learning a language is
just the process of filling in and
understanding that framework from
everything we understand about the
communication systems that animals use
they do not have a universal grammar
like humans we therefore have to assume
that an alien language would be
fundamentally different than ours we
don't know how those structure sentences
we don't even know if they'll have
sentences the problem is if we just
receive a natural language transmission
there's really nothing we can do when
deciphering ancient languages linguist
figure out meaning using context and
relations to other languages but with an
alien language transmission there is no
context and no other similar languages
to compare it with all this is assuming
that aliens use a verbal language and
that's a huge assumption many if not
most animals have no verbal
communication system
fish and chameleons alter their body
color to communicate while ants and
honeybees use pheromones to talk to
other members of their species even if
we understood their language could we
understand what they're saying take this
sentence in French translating it
literally word-for-word gets you the
palace verb on is the name commonly
given to the building that houses the
assembly national French located on the
Kiev or say in the seventh borough of
Paris of the square of the Concorde even
if you clean it up to a structure it
like an English sentence how much
meaning is conveyed to you what exactly
is the French National Assembly where is
the Chi of or say where is the seventh
borough where is Concorde Square someone
familiar to Paris and France would
understand what these words mean but
someone from the other side of the world
would infer little meaning from them
philosopher Ludwig Wittgenstein famously
wrote if a lion could speak we would not
be able to understand him language is
all based on cultures and requires a
common frame of reference if you said
I'm taking an uber to get some coffee at
Starbucks there's no way it would
understand what you're saying you have
to explain what uber is then explain
what a car is what the internet is what
a phone is an app coffee Starbucks
stores the monetary system all stuff
that is intuitive to modern humans
translating the words of an
extraterrestrial civilization is just
the first step understanding what
they're saying is the more difficult
task centuries or millennia after
detecting aliens we might reach a day
when an extraterrestrial being comes to
earth if this happens the alien
civilization is almost certainly more
advanced than humans since it has
accomplished interstellar travel and
perhaps even faster than light travel
but we want to show that us humans are
intelligent as well of course the et
would see everything that humans have
built but they might interpret the
structures of mankind as natural
phenomenons we can't assume that they
think that buildings and cars and
artificial light are not part of a
natural structure of Earth we therefore
need to show them that we have at least
a basic understanding of the universe
math as far as we know is universal no
matter where you go or who you ask 2
plus 2 is 4 and the ratio of a circles
circumference to diameter is 3.14159 2
and so on and so forth
of course what you call two or four or
PI would be different but the concepts
are the same therefore we could show the
aliens our understanding of math put 2
then 2 & 4 4 & 4 then 8 keep this going
until they get the point although
perhaps the best mathematical principle
to demonstrate would be the Pythagorean
theorem it's complicated
but easy to show the Pythagorean theorem
of course demonstrates that in the case
of a right triangle the square of the
side opposite to the right angle is
equal to the square of the other two
sides combined in an equation that reads
a squared plus B squared equals C
squared
visually we can demonstrate this by
drawing squares on the two shorter sides
out of smaller squares and show how the
amount of squares on the two sides
equals the amount of squares on the
longer side showing this theorem cements
that humans do understand how the
mathematical aspect of our universe
works even though were less advanced
than the aliens so now that we've found
the aliens now that we have met them we
can talk to them someone needs to speak
first but let's say was you let's say
you were given the chance to ask the
first question from humanity to an
extraterrestrial being you became the
first point of contact between humanity
and the universe what would you ask I
hope you enjoy this win over productions
video these videos are hugely expensive
to make and I can only do it thanks to
the help of my patreon supporters I have
to buy stock footage buy music hire a
sound designer pay for programs pay for
hardware and that's not even taking into
account the time that I personally put
into these videos if you'd like to make
sure that I can keep doing these videos
and make them better and better please
consider supporting me on patreon by
clicking here every dollar contributed
is spent directly on the channel none of
it goes to me and I'm held to that by
releasing expense reports at the end of
each month there are also some great
rewards including early access to videos
stickers Henry in letters and most
recently t-shirts you can also order a
t-shirt by itself for only $20 through
dftba the link is here and also in the
description other than that please make
sure to follow me on twitter at
of a pro watch my last video on why
cities are where they are here check out
my fan moderate subreddit here and most
of all subscribe to this channel to
receive all my future videos right when
they come out thanks again for watching
and I'll see you in two weeks for
another Wendover productions video